dans le coeur de la ville Satie j'ai
beaucoup aimé votre nouvelle album Zion
il était taillé sur mesure pour l'été
2023 il y a même un grand cri d'amour
pour Montréal et ça tombe bien parce que
vous allez ouvrir les Franco vendredi
prochain qu'est-ce que ça signifie pour
vous c'est tellement reconnaissant
d'être ça ou déjà faire les Francos ça a
toujours été un rêve quand j'étais jeune
puis là en plus d'être sur le Big stage
puis d'ouvrir le show d'ouverture
quoi demander de plus quoi demander de
mieux c'est tellement c'est tellement
reconnaissant pour ça puis cœur de la
ville c'est ça le dit c'est Montréal
j'ai tellement Chili dans tous ses
raccoins dans toutes les quartiers
chaque quartier sa couleur chaque
quartier à son verre d'une certaine
façon c'est puis là d'être je te demande
un cœur de la ville dans le centre-ville
puis performer ça devant je sais pas
combien de personnes c'est c'est
vraiment c'est un statement d'arriver là
dans le bureau
vous êtes un petit gars du plateau est
vous avez fait du rap dès l'adolescence
et lâcher l’école pour faire du rap
c'est un pari audacieux le rap c'est le
hip-hop le rasta c'est tout de votre vie
dans le fond ouais j'imagine que moi
j'ai jamais vraiment pris de cours de
musique ou étant petit j'aille c'est ça
de lire la musique je trouvais ça trop
compliqué maintenant j'ai en découvert
en découvrant aussi le rap québécois
c'est de dire ah on peut rapper comme
comme on parle ici moi j'avais jamais vu
ça j'avais même pas que ça existait si
je pensais qu'il fallait rappeler à la
française ou à l'américaine mais que tu
fais pas râper comme on se parle en ce
moment puis ça ça a été plein de choses
qui ont fait que maintenant j'ai décidé
j'ai fait l'école ça me sert à rien si
j'ai envie de faire du rap au final j'ai
quand même eu mon secondaire 5 aux
adultes puis on dirait que la semaine
que j'ai eu mon son R5 la semaine
d'après j'ai signé chez septième ciel la
semaine d'après c'est comme on dirait
les bons petits Jésus il voulait que
j'aille mon son R5 pour que ça se passe
bien
[Musique]
le secret de fou qui c'est deux choses
tout d'abord la rime qui est très forte
parce que vous mélangez l'anglais le
français où trouvez-vous ces mots qui
fonctionnent vraiment avec vos mélodies
donc finalement je suis né à Montréal
dans mes cours et on n'est pas juste des
Québécois pour laine là parenthèse puis
j'ai toujours été
ça m'a toujours voyons attiré aussi les
autres langues les autres nationalités
les autres cultures puis je trouve que
ça représente juste bien Montréal
d'aller chercher un peu de tout ça c'est
d'aller chercher je sais pas moi un mot
arabe un mot créole un mot espagnol avec
de l'anglais du français c'est Montréal
c'est ma copine
dans plusieurs de vos chansons je pense
à copilote ou encore dans le ciel il y a
toujours une petite pause de guitare là
pourquoi puis qu'est-ce que vous inspire
là-dedans dans la petite guitare le
petit
[Musique]
c'est parce que au Québec je veux pas on
est un peu c'est des francophones dans
un pays anglophone mais faut pas oublier
qu'il y en a d'autres des francophones
aussi hors du Québec et puis je trouvais
ça le fun d'aller chercher un acadien
aussi
les autres sont encore même plus sous
les Anglais d'une certaine façon
je trouvais ça d'aller au-delà de la
Saint-Jean-Baptiste mais aussi de la un
peu d'une fête de la langue française au
Canada tu sais
puis j'ai hâte de la performer
d'ailleurs à la fête nationale j'ai vu
votre horaire sur Internet l'été 2023 ça
s'est chargé le rendez-vous survivre
mais je t'avoue qui est comme un
Gaspésie posé la Madeleine c'est de la
gédée matin midi soir vous avez le seul
à tourner
une petite crevette bientôt
sans rien c'est vraiment dommage de la
Gaspésie votre tour
en plus mon père moi il vient de La
Courneuve
sur ce pour qui merci beaucoup ben
écoute merci à toi je te souhaite bien
de la gagner
les deux ensemble ça se fait aussi ouais
ça se fait un spaghetti